[Música]
y como ya lo decíamos ahora en directo
ahora vamos a Estados Unidos porque la
fiscalía general de Maryland identificó
a 600 Víctimas de abusos sexuales muchas
de ellas menores de edad por parte de al
menos 158 religiosos las autoridades
señalaron además que los crímenes fueron
encubiertos por las autoridades
eclesiásticas conectamos con Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 en
Washington Cristóbal que otros detalles
se conocen de estos casos
pues después de una investigación de
casi cuatro años el fiscal general de
Maryland Frost pide una moción a la
corte de circuito de Baltimore en esta
moción le pide el permiso para publicar
468 páginas de esta investigación donde
demuestra el fiscal general que cerca de
158 curas abusaron de más de 600 menores
de edad o personas durante casi 80 años
esta investigación Data de
1940 eran tan frecuentes los abusos dice
el fiscal que las víctimas terminaban
reportando estos casos a otros curas que
también estaban involucrados en esta
investigación y acusados de abuso sexual
además se dice que está en esta
investigación que la arquidiócesis de
Baltimore no solamente trató de encubrir
esto sino que a pesar de las
cuestionamientos a pesar de las quejas
de los jóvenes trataron de encubrir a
muchos curas durante muchos años bueno
usted ya lo estaba diciendo el documento
de la fiscalía indica que la
arquidiócesis de Baltimore ayuda a
cubrir los casos que puede ocurrir si
los responsables son hallados culpables
pues Además este caso viene justamente
20 años después de que el Boston globe
publicara esta famosa investigación que
destapó los primeros casos numerosos de
uso sexual de la Iglesia Católica acá en
Estados Unidos y lo que puede ocurrir es
lo que ha venido haciendo varias
arquidiócesis recordemos que esto pasó
también en el 2018 en Pensilvania donde
se conocieron numerosos cientos de casos
de abusos de curas a menores y lo que
terminaba pasando era que las
arquidiócesis y las iglesias pues
terminaban negociando haciendo acuerdo
con las víctimas acuerdos
multimillonarios con las víctimas para
pues no permitir que esto avanzara a
estrados legales lo que termina pasando
también en muchos estados es que aunque
se capturan algunos el curas acusados y
de estos crímenes de abuso sexual Pues
hay estados que protegen a las
instituciones religiosas entonces pues
ya no solamente Mary ganó 20 estados en
Estados Unidos han tratado de eliminar
estas protecciones de la ley Estatal a
estas instituciones religiosas
precisamente para poder investigar y
enjuiciar a los responsables sin embargo
muchos analistas se quejan de que frente
a estos casos de abuso sexual sigue
habiendo mucha impunidad por tratarse de
instituciones religiosas que tratan de
cubrir a los responsables